[Music]
look out Eddie Murphy look out Tom
Cruise
do people call you Freddie when they
meet you I get that a lot I get I I get
you know hey Freddy yo Freddy at a
stoplight a lot of that yeah
it's Mr Krueger to you punk
[Music]
seven sequels a horror series TV show
appearances music videos and even a
video game England's career as Freddy
all started in 1984. welcome to Freddy
Freddy has a personality which makes him
distinct from most of the Contemporary
horror films I think the movies are
really a hit though because they take
place in a dream and in the nightmare
you're thrown into this world this
Dreamscape and you never know when the
dream is going to begin or end you never
know when you're out of the dream or not
this is just a dream he isn't real
[Applause]
and check out this movie Magic E.T was
on set with England 37 years ago this
transformation into Freddy took four
hours every night each piece is baked
it's never reusable
and then it's painted
right next to your uh
Lean Cuisine you have little pieces of
Flesh
[Music]
you know there's so many special effects
in a in a horror film and you kind of
got to get the jokes out because you've
got you know you've got tubes going up
through your pant leg and up your bum
and out the sides and there's blood
squirting and I'm wearing goat bladders
under my latex makeup to make my head
expand and and it's kind of ridiculous
did you ever walk anywhere as Freddy
during filming just in public we went to
this dark Thai restaurant and I was
facing the door to the kitchen and an
old waiter came through the door The
Swinging Door and he opened it up and he
had a full tray
stacked with covered dishes and he got
one look at me sitting there in full
Freddy drag he lost the tray it went
clattering to the floor and I learned
real early on I've got to really be
careful where I go in public in that
makeup
[Music]
foreign
it was the first time we saw this A-list
actor ever on the big screen give me
your full name and correct spelling
first my name is Johnny Depp d-e double
P Johnny Depp was just 21 years old that
was incredible and I never acted before
ever in high school and
nothing
so to me it was just it was sort of
trial by fire you know let's see what
happens why would anybody want to kill
me don't he was the most polite guy in
the world he called me sir for the first
two weeks I said Johnny you're making me
feel ancient here
and let's talk about
ground for the man with the metal claw
glove back in January it sold for nearly
3 million bucks and while the inside may
have gotten major upgrades over the
years the outside
[Music]
it looks the same
I'm wary of those little girls with a
jump rope singing that song one two
Freddy's coming for you
[Music]
do you get transported back a little bit
to those late nights of shooting yeah no
you know it's strange mostly people are
worried about losing the light when
you're filming well we were worried
about losing the night because so much
of a horror movie takes place at night
espresso shots coffee what are you doing
well then I think it was jolt cola
[Music]